du côté du front national du côté des
perdants le front national c'est un peu
moins de 30 4% donc sur le résultat hier
soir on est loin des 40% a annoncé ce
plafond vers une nouvelle fois nicolas
dans les yvelines le résultat est plus
faible encore pour la formation de
marine le pen
oui en effet wilfrid le front national
ne dépasse pas la barre des 23 % sur le
département même dans la seule mairie fn
d'ile-de-france à mantes-la-ville marine
le pen réalise un score inférieur à sa
performance nationale 31,96 % avec plus
de 33 % d'abstention donc que marine le
pen n'a pas réussi à mobiliser sur ce
terreau et idéologique du front national
sur l'ensemble du département le fn pour
ce second tour rassemble près de cent
cinquante mille bulletins exprimés soit
51 mille de plus qu'il ya deux semaines
est aussi beaucoup plus qu'il y avait 15
ans en 2002 jean marie le pen avait
réuni au second tour 94 mille voix sur
sa candidature progression donc pour le
fn dans les yvelines mais trop peu
encore écouter le secrétaire
départemental du parti
nous avons toujours été en difficulté
sur les yvelines on a un électorat qui
qui hésitent au changement et donc on a
véritablement fait c'est cette
perception de poursuit dans la
continuité de protection des même si
c'est tout à fait illusoire mais je
pense que c'est ça qui a voulu jouer sur
cet électorat aux yvelinois et et le
report de voix des fillonistes suspense
a été insuffisant trop faible parce que
justement il y avait cette crainte
à nous donc de rassurer et convaincre
les personnes qui sont accrues mais
aussi parce qu'on a beaucoup et si on
resserre à présent sur saint quentin en
yvelines sur l'agglomération le score de
marine le pen est encore inférieure aux
scores départementale marine le pen est
en dessous des 20% vous le voyez avec un
total de 19 1286 voit précisément elle
réalise son meilleur score à coignières
avec 24 13% des suffrages pire score à
montigny le bretonneux la ville la plus
peuplée d'ailleurs c'est à noter avec 15
84% pour marine le pen
attention là aussi c'est comme pour le
reste du département le fn fait sur
chacune des douze communes plus qu'il y
a à 15 ans donc c'est à relativiser
évidemment pour le front national lors
de l'accession au second tour de jean
marie le pen face à jacques chirac on
s'en souvient en 2002 alors